تم طرح اسمي كرئيسه للوزراء وكان ذلك حتى
في عهد شراك في العام 2006 وبعد ذلك تم
تعيين دومينيك دوبلبا لماذا هذا الامر ليس
من سماتي اي ممارسه ضغوط للحصول على هذا
المنصب او ذاك المناصب كلها التي تم
اقتراحها عليه لم اطالب بها وعلينا ان نقر
انه كان هناك رئيسه وزراء سابقه انا احب
دائما ان اكون الاولى لان هذا الامر يشكل
اضافه بالنسبه لي اعتقد ايضا انه كان في
محيط جاك شيراك كما في محيطنك ولا ساكوزي
اشخاص يعاردون وجود سيده في هذا المنصب
ربما لان رئيسه الوزراء الاشتراكيه
السابقه لم يخالفها الحظ وبالنظر الى صفات
القويه ربما لم يحصل ذلك جاك شيراك قال لي
اطلب لي الوزاره التي تريدينها قبل اعينك
رئيسه للحكومه او ان تكوني مرشحه لرئاسه
الجمهوريه لاحقا فقلت له لا اريد هذا
المنصب وكنت اعلم ان دومينيك دوفيل بان قد
التقى جاك شيراك ليكون هو رئيسا للوزراء
بينما انا لم اقوم بهذه الخطوه هذه
العلاقه مختلفه رئيس الجمهوريه يختار رئيس
الحكومه وتاليا لم احصل على هذا المنصب
وهذا ليس مهما ولكنني كنت اول وزيره
الداخليه واول وزيره للخارجيه ايضا وهذه
شكل التحديات لي
البعض يقول ان ذلك لانه كان هناك علاقه
قويه جدا تربته بالرئيس تركزي انه كان
يريدك فعلا لرئاسه الحكومه ولكن ذلك تعرقل
بسبب فضيحه
لا اعتقد ذلك بعد ذلك الوقت كانت هناك
مشاكل تتعلق نيكولا ساكوزي هذا الامر لم
يكن يعنيني لم اهتم لمجال التمويل ولكن لا
اعتقد انه كان لهذا الامر دور في ذلك
الوقت كان خياره بين رجل وامراه رجل يتمتع
بمزايا معينه وسيد لديها خصال مختلفه